but those those resources are available
to call in though because we have face
conditions before where
that has not been the case i
think thank you for that follow-up uh
the national system is absolutely
strange
so we we have to work with what we have
and oregon even among
all the challenges that the nation is
facing is certainly
high up there relative to the priorities
and at this
level of resource drawdown and fire risk
across the west
from northern rockies washington down to
california
there is absolutely strain in the system
uh it'll be
slower than any one of us will like uh
relative to bringing in resources
because we are running out of crews
running out of uh all assets uh to put
on
all these players so we'll have to be
strategic about prioritizing where we
put those limited resources
and that's why we tap into other uh
access points like the national gas
and then the military properties then
also deployed
northern rockies in california and that
helps take pressure out of the system
for resources
hey thank you ted and the last question
is uh dick
dick reader
yes thank you very much um
i drove very carefully up back road
uh to around lions uh and gates
this morning and uh just to survey the
damage
and so my first question is it
there there was sort of a patchwork of
of losses one house lost
but the house next to it seemingly fine
is that
and that's pretty common but is that
what we're seeing
or uh are there whole communities and
neighborhoods that are
wiped out then my second question is
driving back to salem
um on westbound highway 22 which was
open
i saw a lot of cars going around the
roadblocks
and traveling east on closed highway 22.
i just wondered what enforcement if any
was being done
on actually uh dealing with folks who
were
traveling the closed spot the closed
highway
thank you dick this is governor brown
i will just tell you that um we know
that
there have been a number of communities
substantially impacted by
these fires from blue river and vita
in the lane county area we know that
phoenix and talent in southern oregon
um there have been a number of small
communities that have been
um severely devastated by these fires
but i also know and i'll let the experts
speak i also know and and
and touring the moser creek fire this
past year
um that happened frankly just a few
weeks ago
that fire can be very fickle and i saw
a property where there were four
generations of a family living there
the entire property was literally
wiped through the fire and then
literally right over
the fence the neighbor's property was
untouched
so marianna do you want to respond to
that
and provide more detail please
yes governor um those words are exactly
right
in regards to the fire here in the
canyon
fire moves in many different ways based
on
the type of fire we're seeing and the
wind so it's very often you'll run into
a community where you're seeing
patch bluffs and in some cases
complete loss and i think you'll see
that a patchwork
of loss and non-loss on all of these
fires
but to the government's point organiams
are going to be experiencing
significant loss not only in life
but in property and those are things
that we're continuing
to look through as we engage into those
communities
mariana can you speak to enforcement um
we're obviously concerned about people
driving up to look at
um fire sights
yes good question uh sorry for the
follow up uh yeah
on these fires we have uh are working in
coordination
with not only law enforcement but odot
in addition i'm looking
to the national guard for future
requests to
assist in those areas on this fire
specifically the san em
fire there are many individuals who have
not only emergency vehicles but other
type of vehicles
so not knowing specifically it could
very well have been a responder
or a team member it is being
coordinated through the oregon
department or the oregon department of
transportation on this fire
and as the fire progresses or changes
and we are putting those checkpoints in
place
thank you i think that concludes our
conference today
again i want to say to our first
responders to our firefighters to our
national guards men and women to our
emergency personnel our law enforcement
and our red cross thank you for your
service we are incredibly grateful for
your
dedication and determination to saving
lives and
saving property throughout oregon to the
oregonians that have been impacted
by these devastating fires my heart goes
out to you
we will work with everything we have to
make sure that you have the resources
and tools that you need to recover
please stay safe out there please be
careful and if you are in a community
where an evacuation order
is issued please respond
you may not get a second chance
uh
so
you